all right a team that has been very good
in recent years the philadelphia eagles
they won the super bowl just two years
ago if you didn't hear and and got to
the final eight last year we were
talking about the eagles within the
context of the weekly power rankings as
a team in the middle of the pack at
three and four
that maybe could find their way out of
the weeds and i i say that based upon
what they did last year when we wrote
them off but you know chris this year
taking a look at the schedule the games
they have left yeah oh boy
they're in the midst of a three-game
road trip that started at minnesota lost
continued at dallas loss and now goes to
buffalo where there very well could be a
loss waiting for the eagles although if
the bills play like they did last sunday
maybe they can steal it then home stand
against the bears patriots and seahawks
are you kidding me now at least the
bears aren't as good as we thought they
were going to be but the patriots and
the seahawks that seahawks game by the
way sunday night football week 12 unless
there's a flex there because there's
another game that we were talking about
earlier this week that uh was
fascinating for that spot i think it's a
49ers game maybe 49ers saints week 12.
it's 49ers somebody week 12. um but
what's up
49ers packard 49ers packers there you go
so um you know there's some weak spots
there but by the time they get to the
weak spots it could be over it could be
done for the eagles because if they you
know they lose the buffalo if they don't
beat the bears they go into the by they
still have two losses potentially
waiting for them at home from the
patriots and the seahawks yeah by the
time you get to the dolphins the giants
washington the cowboys and the giants to
end the season it may not matter and
this could be an eagles team that i had
picked to go to the super bowl that is
in the process of falling apart me too
mike i had him going to the super bowl
too but it's it's been a lot of injuries
malik jackson timmy jernigan's heard
right now we've talked about ronald
darby avante maddox being banged up i
mean desean jackson on the offensive
side of the ball you know jason peters
you know banged up dealing with injuries
there you know they lost dallas goddard
for a little you know a little time a
week or so
that's where i worry about them they are
like you've always said the ultimate
backs against the wall type of football
team but yeah they're going up to
buffalo is dangerous this week you know
you mentioned it buffalo didn't play
well last week and won they're going to
be like a little more focused in those
are teams that i always look at to go
that's dangerous when the team doesn't
play well and they won
that means like there's not going to be
the pressure in the building but there's
going to be a lot of attention to decal
because they know and they're not going
to be happy with the way they played
last week so that's that's scary the
bears the week after
scary i mean
the bears defense is good the eagles
offense is average the eagles defense is
not good even the crappy bears offense
might be able to move the ball a little
on the eagles right now so you look at
that then bye week patriots seahawks
like you said they might be in trouble
are done before they ever get healthy
and and the more it goes the more i
think they are in trouble and they're
not going to be able to rebound this
year
and it really is amazing to me
i conditioned my faith in the eagles as
a super bowl team on the ability of
carson wants to stay healthy yeah and he
has yeah the problem is everyone around
him has fallen apart right yeah yeah
they've all fallen apart
and i almost made this my grievance
today too mike would like because people
i've had people ask me like what's you
know what what's wrong with carson wentz
or what's he doing i want to be like
what i mean carson wentz is the only guy
only thing going for philadelphia right
now it's it's not what's wrong with
carson wentz it's what the hell's wrong
with everybody else they need to help
them i mean gosh i've never quarterback
getting crushed you saw some of the hits
he took the other night i mean he took
some big hits when they make a play
it's not because of the system it's
usually carson wentz making something
happen over just with his physical
ability so uh yeah they have a lot of
issues across the board right now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports